the Ukrainian flag still flies at the
Village Hall of lemony but only just
two nights ago it was struck by one of
the many Russian shells that's rained
down on this community this building is
normally guarded at night but luckily
for them the security guards were given
the night off
most people fled the city and come back
just to feed the dogs and cats God
forbid the Russians come but if they do
we will defend ourselves
the retired School principal Nadia lives
opposite
she tells me her Windows blew in as the
shell landed
I see that our Warriors are doing
everything in their power to not let the
Russians through Mika live behind our
back is mikolai We Are The Shield of
make alive
make alive is the main shipbuilding town
of the Black Sea and blocks Russia's
road to Odessa and this so-called Shield
of mikolaev is just a village of small
Holdings to the southeast its remaining
population mostly retired live in Terror
eight kilometers from the Russian lines
Shelter From the shelling is now
building basement
it shakes really badly it wasn't built
for shelling it was built for storing
pickles we were afraid the ceiling would
come down on our heads this is
svetlana's Bunker with shrapnel holes in
the walls and if you cross the road here
just 20 meters away is a hole where one
of the shells landed ripping down this
tree spreading shrapnel everywhere and
just across the Horizon there is nothing
but Farmland between this Village and
the Russian positions
oh my God but this is a town of Lucky
escapes shells landed either side of
this house destroying the garage
residents were next door having coffee
two doors down they were running for the
basement when it had a direct hit before
they reached it
you struggle and struggle and work to
build your home and in one minute they
take it away from you and you're left
without anything
each incoming shell is a roll of the
dice there's no strategy or military
objective to striking this local
kindergarten nearly every window blasted
out thankfully it was closed this is no
place for children
and not everyone has a lucky Escape
34 year old Sergey poyukov died five
days ago when his home was struck they
call it Putin's War but these are the
people paying the price
Jason Farrell Sky News lemony